>>Waleed Kadous: Welcome.
Thank you very much.
It's so great to see all of you here.
My name is Waleed Kadous and with me is Jaikumar
Ganesh, and we're the tech leads on the Android
location team.
And we're super, super excited today to be
sharing with you some of the new features
for location we've added to Android.
This is probably the biggest change in location
since Android was released and we wanted to
walk you through some of the changes that
we have planned.
So let's get down to the specifics.
What's changed?
We really want to talk a little bit about
what's changed that made us want to make these
modifications to location in Android.
And there's two major sets of changes.
One is the prominence of new types of apps
and then the other one is some of the underlying
technology for location has also evolved,
and we're going to walk you through those.
Then we're going to talk about some of the
technologies we've added that were mentioned
in the keynote yesterday, the fused location
provider, the geofencer, activity recognition.
We're going to take you behind the curtain,
show you how we built those things and how
they work and we might have some live demos
so there's the potential for us to crash and
burn.
And finally after that we're going to have
the opportunity to look ahead and to really
see what the potential of some of these new
location APIs are.
So let's dive right in.
One of the changes is the growing importance
of location.
So a lot of the most popular apps now, if
you go to the app store, they're using location.
And a huge number of applications across the
board are using location.
You know, Google Maps, G+, Facebook, Twitter,
Google Now, all the really prominent applications.
And we really wanted the opportunity to improve
the quality of those three things.
When I say quality with respect to location
it means three things and I'm going to keep
coming back to them, power, accuracy, coverage.
Not just that, but there's this new type of
app that's coming around that we're calling
contextual applications.
Those are the things that Larry and Amit were
talking about, the Star Trek computer at the
keynote yesterday, phones that are smarter,
things that we can use to make the phones
smarter so that the user can get on with their
lives and those annoying tedious things that
can just disappear.
How we can make, as Reto said, those applications
more magical.
So one example of the contextual app is Google
Now.
Who uses Google Now?
And how do you like it?
Yeah.
And so that for us is an example of an awesome
contextual app, but let's do a deep dive for
a second and see how central location is to
that app.
So we took all of the cards that were in Google
Now, the team from Google Now is just awesome.
They keep adding cards.
But they did a survey and remember that Google
Now is meant to be a contextual app for all
types of contexts.
But the thing that you realize very quickly
is a huge fraction of the cards that Google
Now makes available rely intrinsically, deeply
on location.
And we think this is true of many contextual
apps.
If you want to build a Star Trek computer
how can you do that without knowing where
you are on the Star Trek Enterprise?
That's the thing that we're trying to say.
So if you really want to build world class
contextual apps you need to have high quality
location.
But here's the issue, and this is why we introduced
some of those changes.
It's because the requirements of contextual
apps like Google Now are a little bit different
to apps like Google Maps.
So if you look on the left-hand side you have
Google Maps.
Think about how you use this.
You use Google Maps when you need information
right now.
It's task oriented.
You open Google Maps and then you try to accomplish
something.
It's very different to Google Now.
Google Now sometimes will notify you and sometimes
you will just pull it out and expect it to
have something there waiting and ready for
you to go.
The usage model is different and the requirements
for location are different.
So for instance, let's look at one aspect,
which is power.
So if you're running Google Maps, here are
some power numbers.
I know that power is really intrinsic to these
questions of location.
When the screen is on it's pulling about 350
milliwatts.
When the processor is on it's pulling about
300 milliwatts.
By comparison GPS is pulling 100 milliwatts.
So that means that GPS is consuming somewhere
in the realm of only 13, 14 percent of the
power when you have the screen on and when
you're looking at a map.
But if you have something like Google Now
on and you were pulling 100,000 milliwatts,
you would be so creaky and users would be
dumping your app right then and there.
So you have to be very careful with power.
And the requirements of contextual apps are
very different and you will see that going
through what we do.
So another example is accuracy.
You don't always need super duper accuracy
for something like Google Now.
Whereas for Google Maps if you're indoors
want to know exactly where you are.
So I talked a little bit about the applications
that we might want to develop, the growing
prominence of location.
I talked about, for example, contextual apps
and their ability to add value, but there's
also the technological changes.
And that is that it's becoming very, very
hard to really build high quality location
models for developers.
And it's something you guys shouldn't worry
about.
It's something we should be worrying about
while you focus on building great apps, right?
And here's the issue.
You have now if you really want to build a
high quality app you need to talk to four
different components, GPS, Wi-Fi, cell and
sensors.
And the thing is each of them has different
characteristics.
So for instance, GPS, it's horrible on power.
Like I said, about 100 milliwatts.
By comparison Wi-Fi is about 30 milliwatts,
about a third of the power.
But the thing is that the accuracy of GPS
is really good and Wi-Fi is sometimes it's
good, sometimes it's not quite so good, right?
Coverage on the other hand, GPS doesn't work
indoors, and given how much time people spend
indoors, that's just unacceptable.
And as well as that you have cell, which has
great power because it's basically free, but
the accuracy is pretty bad.
Think half a mile accuracy.
And then there's this new kid on the block,
sensors, which we'll come back to in a few
moments.
So let me again explain a little bit what
I mean about this problem of complexity.
If you really want to build a high quality
app that meets those three characteristics
we talked about, power, accuracy and coverage,
you now have to deal with this mess across
the OS.
You've got the network location provider,
the GPS location provider, you've got to talk
to them.
Then you might want to subscribe to the passive
location provider and then you also have to
talk to the sensors.
Developers shouldn't have to be thinking about
all of those things when all they want is
I just want a location, right?
They shouldn't be thinking about these types
of problems.
And just to kind of hammer home the problem,
this is a screen shot from our documentation
for location right now.
And you can see at the bottom here there's
this timeline that says application starts
and then you get an update from the GPS and
then you get a cell location and you have
to maintain a best estimate.
And any time there's timeline like this in
the documentation you know that the technology
has evolved beyond the point where the old
APIs worked really well and you need to update
your APIs, and that's what we've done.
So I said that there was a couple of different
technological changes.
There's one particular one that I wanted to
highlight, and that is the increasing importance
of sensors.
This last column here on the right.
And they're kind of the new kid on the block
as far as location is concerned.
And I think some of you might be thinking,
well, sensors, great.
They're for games, right?
But the thing is that sensors are actually
amazingly powerful.
So let's take a few moments to discuss the
sensors that are on some of the phones, in
particular the accelerometer and the magnetometer
or the compass.
They're like on all the phones, but really
good phones will have all four of these sensors,
the accelerometer for horizontal, and vertical
movement; the gyro for rotational speeds,
the compass and magnetometer for which way
is north and barometer for elevation.
And you might be saying, well, I mean, think
back to what we were talking about yesterday
at the keynote.
I mean, there's questions there about making
our phones smarter and these sensors are a
really huge, important part of that.
And I want to give you an example just about
what we're talking about in location of three
things we can do.
We can use these sensors to save power.
A lot of the time people are just sitting
still.
If you're sitting here in this room with your
phone in your pocket, why do we need to even
try to calculate your location once we know
what it was, right?
We can check the accelerometer and that will
tell us about movement.
We can also do things like detect the activity,
so if someone is driving, we can check for
location more frequently.
If someone is sitting still, then we don't
need to do that as often.
And finally, it can have a huge impact on
quality.
And what I'm going to do now is I'm going
to show you some of the data from our location,
our indoor location, and that's really where
sensors come into their own.
So here we go.
Can folks see this?
It's okay?
Good.
All right.
So here's what happens.
Over here you have the green dot.
The green dot is the ground truth.
This is the Bloomingdale's just behind the
center here.
So behind Moscone you can actually go visit
this venue.
Green is ground truth that a member of the
Google team went and collected this data.
And yellow is our best estimate once we mix
Wi-Fi and all of the other sensors together
to give a good estimate.
And you can see it's not exactly perfect.
It's just going to start animating now, in
a moment hopefully.
There we go.
And you can see as the green dot moves around
the yellow dot does a pretty good job, not
always, of following around the green dot.
It doesn't jump radically, it doesn't move
around.
As you can see over there it's following just
ever so slightly behind.
And you can see that we can -- that's where
we use the sensors to really get that smooth,
high quality result.
Now, one of the key inputs to indoor location
is the Wi-Fi, but I wanted to show you how
bad just the Wi-Fi by itself was.
So I want you to see how much the Wi-Fi jumps
around.
And we talked about this a little bit before.
Watch this.
It just jumps to the other side of the building.
Someone got between -- again, it's jumping
all over the place.
But by using the sensors on the phone we're
able to smooth this out and give a really
good prediction of where the user is.
Let's go back to the presentation now.
There we go.
All right.
So our goals in this effort of introducing
these new features was really along these
lines.
First of all, we've got to get the power down.
We hear you loud and clear.
Location takes too much power, but it's so
critical to contextual apps that we had to
fix this problem.
The second is we wanted to get that accuracy
up and that coverage up so that you could
use it indoors and we could have like higher
accuracy.
And we also heard from developers that location
was just too hard to use, so we wanted to
really make it easier for you guys.
And we can also do things like optimize more
efficiently across the OS by looking at all
of the different location requests.
We also wanted to show you some of the awesome
new things you can do with sensors, and most
importantly we wanted to make it available
on as many Android devices as possible.
Millions are not just good enough.
We need hundreds of millions of devices that
can use this API.
And with that I would like to hand over to
my colleague Jaikumar to walk us through these
changes.
[ Applause ]
>>Jaikumar Ganesh: So the first thing we want
to talk about today is the fused location
provider.
We want to move from this where the developer
has to take care of the sensor manager, the
GPS location provider, the network location
provider, location manager, to this, where
the developer doesn't have to worry about
the integer, platform and hardware components.
So simply finding the APIs here was our main
goal, but you may say, hey, we are engineers.
We really want to understand what's happening
under the hood.
To help you explain what's happening under
the hood we have a bunch of videos.
In this video the green dot represents the
actual location and the yellow dot here represents
the GPS location.
You will see that GPS tracks the location
fairly well when the person is outside, but
as the person enters the building GPS basically
has dropped dead at the door.
The person is now going through the various
corridors and we have completely lost track
of the location.
Exits the building and you see that GPS puts
you right in the middle of the parking lot.
See the big jump from the door to the parking
lot.
The person had not even reached the parking
This is a Google building and this is actually
one of our Google team members collecting
the data.
Waleed just mentioned about Wi-Fi.
So how does Wi-Fi compare to the actual location?
Again, green is the actual location, red is
the Wi-Fi location.
It's basically useless when you're outside.
Indoors, seems okay.
A bit jumpy.
User is navigating the corridors.
It's okay.
But then when the user transitions from indoors
to outdoors, you will see that we have kind
of lost track of the location again.
So what did we do?
We took cell, Wi-Fi, GPS and sensors and fused
them together.
So let's see how the fused location looks.
If there's one slide you want to take home,
this will give you a very good indication
of what it is.
The blue dot represents the fused location,
the green dot the actual location.
Following very well when the person is outside,
continues following the actual location when
the person is inside navigating through all
the corridors.
This user looks drunk.
The exit is that way.
[ Laughter ]
>>Jaikumar Ganesh: There you go.
And now notice the transition from indoor
to outdoor will be much more smoother than
when we were using GPS.
The GPS put you in the middle of the parking
lot.
This one is much more smoother.
[ Applause ]
>>Jaikumar Ganesh: All right.
So let's have a closer look at the APIs.
Before that I wanted to talk about two things,
listeners and pending intent.
Most of you are familiar with the register
a listener call.
Your app registers a listener, the location
process will give you a synchronized callback
(indiscernible).
That works very well if you are in the foreground,
your maps application, navigation application,
but there's this new class of applications
that we just talked about, contextual apps,
that walk around in the background.
So you don't have to be -- your process doesn't
have to be tightly bound to the location process.
This is where pending intents come into play.
So what's a pending intent?
It's a token that your app process will give
to the location process and the location process
will use it to wake up your app when anything
of interest happens.
So this basically means that your app in the
background doesn't have to be always running.
When something of interest happens we will
wake you up.
This saves a lot of battery.
All right.
So before I -- now that I've talked about
pending intents and listeners, let's have
a closer look at the APIs.
You create an instance of the location client,
you call connect on it, you get a call back
on connected.
You get -- you call the function get last
location on the location client object.
You immediately will receive a course location
that is maintained by the system.
The second variant is creating a location
request object.
You set the priority, you set the polling
interval of the location, and the function
that you would call is request location updates.
You send in the location request to object,
you send in the listener, and we will call
your callback on location changed so that
you will get the location -- latest location.
That's it.
Just this one API will give you the blue dot
that you just recently saw in the animation.
[ Applause ]
>>Jaikumar Ganesh: So that's how it worked
with listeners.
What about the pending intent variant?
You create the intent, pending intent, it
calls get service, call request location updates.
Again, the very same function call.
It takes in the location request object, sends
in the pending intent.
You will get a call back with the location
object.
Same API, both use cases.
So I introduced two variants of the APIs.
We have last location and location request
objects.
When do we use them?
So get last location gives you a course location
that is maintained by the system immediately.
So suppose you are a search application that's
looking for movies or a weather application
and you just want the user's city.
Get last location is for you.
But if you're a maps application or navigation
application and you want finer grain control,
you want to set the integral, the priorities,
et cetera, that's when you use the location
request APIs.
I mentioned priority twice, so what exactly
is this?
So for the location request APIs, we are providing
you with three options for priorities, the
high accuracy mode, the balance power mode
and the no power mode.
The high accuracy mode responds to GPS when
you're outside and on Wi-Fi when you're inside.
It is basically used for applications like
maps and navigation applications which want
really good accuracy.
Because they're running in the foreground
the battery drain is fine and the typical
polling interval is around five seconds.
The balance power doesn't use GPS.
It uses cell and Wi-Fi.
It is fine with slightly lower accuracy and
it doesn't want to drain the battery that
much.
So if you have a weather app, this is when
you use the balance power.
The typical polling interval is around 20
seconds.
We have a third mode called the no power mode.
The no power mode is useful when you just
want to get a location if some other app in
the system has requested the location.
You don't want to actively poll, but if the
system knows the location, very well, I can
enhance my app.
So that's when you use the no power mode,
and this is the best part.
Your app will not get any battery blame.
A caveat about accuracy.
Accuracy basically depends on various parameters,
the signal quality, et cetera.
This is a rough guidance with regard to the
three priority options.
All right.
The next topic, geofencing.
What's a geofence?
We'll geofence around an area so when the
user enters or exits the area, the app is
informed.
So you can have a geofence around a Starbucks
location, and so when the user enters a Starbucks
location, your app would inform and, say,
for example, it can give offers that a user
has entered the Starbucks location.
We have two demos for you.
So we are in the middle of a lecture hall
here, so we have this mock sample app which
basically mocks the location way points.
So let me start that.
And this is me driving through Mountain View,
and we have two geofences.
I'm a very cautious driver, following speed
limits.
I have to follow the rules.
I don't want to get tickets.
There we go.
And the user has entered the first geofence.
You can see that the app has got the geofence
entering result and has put the black bottle.
This app is currently showing two geofences.
We support multiple geofences.
>>Waleed Kadous: Wait a second.
How many geofences do we support, Jaikumar?
>>Jaikumar Ganesh: Good point.
So we have heard you guys.
We support 100 geofences per app.
That is a big number and we feel that you
will be able to accomplish a lot of things
you were --
[ Applause ]
>>Jaikumar Ganesh: We feel you will be able
to accomplish a lot of things that you weren't
able to do before.
The user entered the second geofence, and
I hope you saw the circle getting highlighted.
I live in San Francisco.
I like the city life.
But, you know, my office is in Mountain View.
Commute can be hectic so I have been thinking
--
>>Waleed Kadous: Yeah.
I want to make him more (indiscernible) so
I want to move to Mountain View.
>>Jaikumar Ganesh: So the commute can be actually
a bit hectic.
So I use this app called Zillow.
It shows me a bunch of all the open homes,
the homes pending for sale, et cetera.
So two weeks back I listed one such home as
a favorite home.
Zillow app shows me all the photos, descriptions
of what kind of -- the sale price, et cetera.
So this was two weeks back.
Just yesterday I was driving through Mountain
View.
So let's start our location mock app again.
So the user is, again, driving through Mountain
View, and I see this notification on top that
Zillow has put.
It tells me that there was a favorite home
nearby.
There you go.
And I can actually see all the photos and
details of the favorite home.
This was the same favorite home I marked as
a favorite two weeks back.
We were just now talking about contextual
apps.
Zillow used my context, my location, and showed
me a reminder, hey, this home you marked as
favorite two weeks back is just a mile away
from you.
Why don't you go and have a look at it.
This is the power of geofencing.
It allows such contextual apps to be so powerful.
[ Applause ]
>>Jaikumar Ganesh: All right.
So let's look at the APIs.
You create a location client object, call
connect on it just exactly the way you are
doing for the Fused Location Provider.
You get an on connect at call back and you
create a new geofence object.
You set the request ID.
The transition types whether you are interested
in entering or exiting the building.
The type of geofence currently we support,
so clear geofences, the latitude, longitude,
radius, and the time when the geofence will
expire.
One API at geofences, takes a list of geofences
and the pending intent.
When a geofence transition happens, you'll
get a call back.
You can check which geofence has been breached
and what was the transition event.
That's it.
One API for addition, one API for removal,
and you can build these powerful apps.
>>Waleed Kadous: So how long did Zillow take
to make the modifications?
>>Jaikumar Ganesh: So Zillow used our APIs
and they were up and running within a day.
That's all it took.
We said, hey --
[ Applause ]
>>Jaikumar Ganesh: Yeah.
We gave them our sample APIs just to make
sure things worked and they had a demo built
for us.
Some of you might already be familiar with
add proximity alert API in our platform which
does geofencing.
So why did we introduce this new API?
Let's compare the two.
We ran a bunch of tests.
One geofence around the home, one geofence
around work, a bunch of geofences around the
various Starbucks locations.
We ran this test on a repeat of 24 hours on
a Galaxy Nexus and we saw a two-third power
savings.
Two-third power savings.
[ Applause ]
>>Jaikumar Ganesh: Sure.
You can clap for it.
(Inaudible).
And so apart from power savings, the APIs
are much more powerful.
You can add multiple geofences.
It tells you which geofence has been breached.
You can set the various parameters associated
with the geofence.
Now I just now told you we saved a lot of
power.
How did we do it?
Three ways.
You are in San Francisco enjoying the Golden
Gate bridge, but you have a geofence in Hollywood,
Los Angeles.
The phone knows this.
The phone doesn't have to keep polling to
know whether you entered the geofence or not.
The user can be still, the user can be walking.
The phone knows this.
The phone can use this as a signal to configure
its polling interval.
We also want to move to doing things in hardware.
Geofencing is basically a background process.
That means that the application process -- processor
doesn't have to be always (inaudible).
We can do geofencing monitoring in the hardware,
like the GPS hardware, and the hardware can
tell us, hey, the user has entered the geofence.
I just now talked about, you know, monitoring
user state and using it as a signal.
So how did we do it?
So let's talk about activity recognition.
We can use the sensors on the phone -- it's,
after all, a smartphone -- and we can figure
out whether the user is driving, whether the
user is on foot, whether the user is still,
or whether the user is on a bike.
So this is what the actual metadata looks
like when the user is walking and the user
is in a car.
So we used machine learning based classifiers,
a bunch of training data, and we were able
to actively figure out which class of activity
the user is involved in.
So where would you use this?
We gave our APIs to a very popular third-party
application, Endomondo, and these are two
screen shots.
They can give you details of how much time
you have spent walking, how much time you
have spent biking.
They used our APIs and yet again they said
battery life is much, much better.
So let's talk about another application, the
moves app.
So moves app is a third-party tracker app
which automatically detects your activity.
The user just keeps the phone in their pocket,
walks around and they can detect whether you're
cycling, driving, running, et cetera.
So let's open the app.
This is what the app looks like.
It tells me how many steps I have taken today,
how many miles I have biked today.
They have this beautiful timeline.
Let me go to yesterday, and they have this
entire timeline of what I did yesterday.
I went to Washington Square, was in Moscone,
Starbucks.
I biked to Moscone West, so let me click on
it.
And if the network connection works, you'll
see it nicely superimposed on a map.
But let's raise the bar up here a bit.
How about a live demo?
Let's invite Mark on stage.
Mark is the engineer who has done most of
the work for activity recognition.
He has a phone in his pocket which is monitoring
activity.
And there is the (indiscernible) which is
basically listening for it.
You can see that the phone is in tilting state,
which basically means the phone is about to
change the activity.
Mark has started to walk around the stage
behind me, and you can see it's on foot.
This is all live time, real time networking
from his phone in the pocket to this tablet.
[ Laughter ]
>>Jaikumar Ganesh: Mark is on a bike right
now.
The phone has gone to tilting, and there you
go.
It's on a bicycle.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
>>Jaikumar Ganesh: Mark did a really great
job working out, biking every day.
Let's get this working.
Thanks a lot, Mark.
[ Applause ]
>>Jaikumar Ganesh: All right.
The demos, the demos look great but how do
you use it in your app?
That's why we have this slide to have a closer
look at the APIs.
You create a new instance of the activity
recognition client, call connect on it.
When the call back comes you get unconnected.
Again, just one API.
Request activity updates.
Two parameters.
The detection time interval that basically
says how often do you want to poll the system
to get activity updates, and the pending intent.
You get a call back.
You can extract the activity and get the probability.
So the detected activity is basically in vehicle,
on bicycle, on foot, still and tilting.
And we are going to get Mark back to the office
to add more classes to this.
All of these activities have associated probabilities.
One important thing to note, this has a new
permission, the activity recognition permission.
So we talked about Fused Location Provider,
activity recognition and geofencing.
So how can you get these?
We are using the Google Play services to deliver
these APIs to you.
The Google Play services an APK that gets
updated from the Play Store, has two parts,
the client library that you app links against
and the Play services APK process.
The client library is intelligent enough that
it knows to handle older and newer versions
so you don't have to take care of it.
Here is the best part.
The latest APK with all these APIs is already
pushed out, is already there and on the phones.
The documentation is already ready.
So you, in fact, can go start coding right
after this session and you can push an app
today, evening, and it will be live.
[ Applause ]
>>Jaikumar Ganesh: To borrow a word from the
keynote, that's what we call it as auto awesome.
So we moved to Google Play services.
Why did we do that?
Three reasons.
One is it's backward compatible to Froyo so
it gives us hundreds of millions of devices
for free.
[ Applause ]
>>Jaikumar Ganesh: The second reason is that
we have a bunch of indoor floor plans, indoor
data models so we had the potential of using
these floor plans and data models to enhance
the APIs, to add more context, to add more
features so you know all the indoor features
work very well.
The third main reason is the short release
cycle.
You discover a bug, you tell us.
We want to add a new class for active data
recognition.
We can do it much, much faster than waiting
for the platform updates.
So with that I would like to welcome back
Waleed on stage to talk about what's next.
[ Applause ]
>>Waleed Kadous: Thank you very much, Jaikumar.
Thank you very much, Jaikumar.
We really appreciate that.
I wanted to talk about the improvements, and
you're going to see it's the same patents:
accuracy, power, coverage.
And the question is how are we going to do
that.
And we want to share with you some of the
ideas and some of the upcoming technologies
that are coming through.
One is improving accuracy.
So before we mentioned that there were four
sensors: cell, Wi-Fi, GPS sensors -- one other
one, but there's even more coming.
So, for example, Bluetooth low energy is coming
and that will allow us to get even more accurate
location, especially indoors.
There's even standards like 802.11v that takes
the humble Wi-Fi and gets rid of the jumpiness
by adding time of flight.
So there's all of these new technologies that
are coming that are going to improve location
even more.
And we're really excited to be including them,
and the nice thing is you don't have to modify
your app.
We will just add those extra columns to our
list of four things.
We'll do all the work for you.
That's another reason.
The other thing is we can do more intelligent
things with, say, using indoor floor plans
to improve the accuracy.
Not only that, as Jaikumar mentioned when
he was talking about geofencing, we can do
a lot of this on the hardware.
And we are working with hardware vendors to
really improve the standards and improve things
like the hardware abstraction layer for sensors.
And if any of you are interested in -- any
of you are hardware developers and you're
interested in that, please come talk to us
afterwards.
And the progress so far on that has been pretty
amazing.
The other thing is better coverage.
We really want to get indoors.
If you're going to build contextual apps,
you need location that work all of the time
and that's why as part of our efforts we're
expanding our indoor coverage because people
spend so much time indoors.
So thank you very much for your attention
today.
There's a few things I really want you to
take away from today's discussion.
Our obsession, my motto and the team's motto
is, power, accuracy, coverage.
Those are the mottos.
My personal motto is one centimeter location
everywhere always, and that's what we're going
to continue to strive towards.
As well as that, we want to make your lives
easier.
We want to do the heavy lifting for location
so that you guys don't have to.
So we're trying to make these cool -- these
nice interfaces like the Fused Location Provider
for you.
And also, we just want to add some cool stuff
like Activity Recognition.
We've mentioned the APIs before.
The Fused Location Provider gives you simplicity,
lower power, more accuracy.
We talked about Geofencing and Activity Recognition.
And personally, Activity Recognition, that's
what you want to see you guys just explore
what's possible.
Because it's never really been available before.
And yet it's the sensor that's on the phone
that allows us to improve the context.
All of these features are available today
in Google Play Services, on hundreds of millions
of devices.
And we're going to keep adding features.
We're going to add other types of geofences
other than circular ones.
We're going to look at integrating things
like semantic information about place.
We're going to do things like add higher-level
activities.
All of these things are possible.
And we'd love to hear from you more about
these things as we go forward.
>>Jaikumar Ganesh: Waleed, I guess you have
to mention that we are wanting to do the hard
work here.
You guys should just think about apps and
UI and we do the hard work for you.
>>Waleed Kadous: As far as location is concerned,
anyway.
We can't do everything for you.
[ Laughter ]
>>Waleed Kadous: Here's my parting question.
You heard Amit and Larry talk about smarter
phones.
You heard them talk about "Star Trek" computers.
At the heart of context are things like these
sensors that we mentioned, are things like
location.
And what we really want to see you do is,
what apps can you build that make your users'
lives easier using location and activity to
just make your apps get to that next level
higher, to make them magic, like Reto was
talking about in the previous session.
Thank you very much.
There's a few quick messages here.
We have a code lab tomorrow at 11:15 where
we will be walking you through making some
of these changes.
There's the feedback counters at the end.
And we'll be at office hours to answer your
questions about location immediately after
this.
Thank you very much.
We look forward to your questions.
Please come to the mics.
[ Applause ]
>>Waleed Kadous: Any questions?
Come to the mic, please.
We have time for maybe one or two.
>>> You mention there was support for 100
geofences.
Was that per app installation or overall for
an app?
>>Waleed Kadous: 100 geofences per app.
You shouldn't have to think about what other
applications are doing; right?
>>> But, I mean, if your app has multiple
users, each of those users has 100 geofences
available?
>>Waleed Kadous: I think so.
It's per app per user.
We can double-check.
>>Jaikumar Ganesh: We can double-check.
>>> That's important for us.
>>Waleed Kadous: Okay.
Next question.
>>> Hi.
This is Alex Jiminez.
I just wanted to ask, you mentioned something
about you can also do this on devices other
than, you know, the phones.
Is there -- is this going to be also part
of the ADK?
>>Waleed Kadous: We're still exploring that
option.
We don't have an answer right now.
But stay tuned to see what we come up with.
>>> All right.
>>Jaikumar Ganesh: One last.
>>Waleed Kadous: One last question.
>>> This is probably a product of the training
data, but I was wondering if you took into
account things like a user's on a bike and
maybe they have their phone in their backpack
and you're not getting quite the twisting
and tilting data from the sensors.
Does it still recognize situations like that?
>>Waleed Kadous: We've tested many different
types of situations because of the machine
learning, and we've gathered data in those
situations.
It actually pretty well adapts to those situations.
It's not perfect, and sometimes it will report
tilting.
But by and large, it works pretty well.
We've measured pretty high accuracy on it.
>>> Do you also take into account their current
speed to say, maybe 15 miles an hour is about
like a biker's speed?
You're not walking at 15 miles an hour.
>>Waleed Kadous: I'm not sure.
We can double-check that.
>>Jaikumar Ganesh: Meet us at the office hours
and we'll get into the details.
>>> I had a couple quick ones.
Number one, did you -- what's the lag time
between, like, if you switch activities from,
let's say, walking to driving?
What's the lag time between an app getting
that kind of a registration?
>>Waleed Kadous: It varies a little bit from
what the transitions are.
But think on the order of 30 seconds to a
minute.
>>Jaikumar Ganesh: Just to give you an accurate
figure, the live demo here, it took, like,
eight seconds from him to go to biking from
foot to bike when he was -- and in between,
we had the tilting to say that there is an
activity chain.
So we have to, you know, be careful about
false positives and false negatives.
>>> Do you happen to know, is there a way,
given the current driving activity, is there
a way right now that you can tell if you're
just -- if you're a driver or a passenger?
Is that something you might work on?
>>Waleed Kadous: We can't do that right now.
But who knows what the future holds.
>>> All right.
Thank you.
>>Waleed Kadous: All right.
Thank you very much.
We really appreciate your time today.
Please come to the office hours and the code
lab tomorrow.
[ Applause ]